good morning john one of the things that
i am very passionate about is the idea
that understanding something is a lot
more valuable than just knowing that it
exists like this kind of got us into a
bit of a mess when it comes to pluto for
example we taught a whole lot of people
that pluto was a planet and now we're
teaching a whole lot of other people
that pluto isn't a planet but this is
confusing even a little upsetting
because we gave people a lot of
information without any understanding we
taught people that pluto was a planet
but not why pluto was a planet because
when we spotted it we didn't know all of
the things there were to know about the
solar system and maybe we thought it
wasn't that complicated but it turns out
it's actually very interesting pluto is
a part of the kuiper belt just like
ceres is a part of the asteroid belt
except we didn't know that the kuiper
belt existed until i was 12. that is
very interesting but i think sometimes
we avoid that story and instead just say
pluto isn't a planet like that's the
whole story somehow this is like
textbook knowing is as important or even
more important than understanding and
that's just wrong understanding is more
important than note but i often forget
that this extends way beyond just
science stuff which is where i spend a
lot of my time thinking in fact i
remember very explicitly being told what
the proper structure for an essay was
without ever being exposed to the idea
of like why that's a good structure for
an essay or even what the purpose of an
essay is turns out lots of purposes for
essays right now i
am basically performing an essay that i
wrote earlier today i have just finished
the introduction but when i was writing
it i didn't think to myself i need to
write an introduction i thought i need
to hook people in grab their attention
so that i can do some work with them
that introduction is going to hook you
in but it's also going to provide you
some context for the work that we're
going to do
in the body of the essay which we have
now entered see making a great video to
promote a charity is hard making a great
video at all is hard the main thing you
need though is to capture and hold
people's attention and i did that with a
hook that contained two things that
people are passionate about education
and doing it right and pluto a dwarf
planet you need a similar hook when
you're making a project for awesome
video promoting a charity and then you
need this part the body where you're
actually getting the work done right now
we're getting the work done it doesn't
have to be long in fact it's nice if
it's not too long because it's not going
to be as hooky because you need to be
doing work during the body for example
in this case i just gave you information
on how to write a good project for
awesome video and if this were the body
of a project for awesome video it would
be talking about why the work that the
organization does is important why they
are good at doing that work and how they
do it and look that wasn't that
complicated so i'm not going to spend a
lot of time on it in fact as i am
speaking right now we are transitioning
into the conclusion can you feel it
happening it's happening right now the
conclusion is a lot of restating the
case but it can also be some new
information like that making a project
for awesome video is a way to have some
real significant impact now of course
not every charity featured in a project
for awesome video is going to get a
portion of the money that we raise but a
lot of them are and that money can have
real significant impacts for those
organizations and even if it doesn't
have that impact that organization might
use your project for awesome video to
promote the work that they do but you do
have to make a good video and that means
capturing and holding onto people's
attention with some kind of introduction
that might be about something completely
different like this video is about how
to make project for awesome videos but
the introduction was about pluto i've
had 15 years of practice doing this so
i'm not saying that it's easy but it's
not magic it's just work and i just have
to say i deeply appreciate anyone who
takes the time to make a project for
awesome video i'm really excited to see
what you come up with submissions are
open now they close 48 hours before the
project for awesome starts on the 25th
capture and hold attention however you
can make a clear simple case don't
overstay your welcome and john i'll see
you on tuesday